so I'm at the store buying a couple
bottles of wine which normally I
wouldn't give a second thought about but
because I'm going this [ __ ] this
shirt I feel like people are gonna see
me with a couple bottles of wine and be
like oh wow she must be so sad how long
have I been seeing it's been at least
two years in 2013 I'm [ __ ] I just
wanted to be known that I have had sex
it's cuffing season now so I'm ready for
a boyfriend like yesterday all righty
I'm single that's straight to the point
I don't get it what is this one trying
to say this guy's single I love all the
big bold text this is like very
aggressive I feel like these are
monopolizing on my sadness reasons why
I'm single
ugly too picky dick is too big I don't
want to kill someone
I think this shirt could get me a date
but I just have to defend this shirt in
a very funny way maybe I might go with
this one it's just you know putting it
all out there this one's growing on me
it's just so cheesy that was more my
style okay a little bit humor in it we
see what amis a little bit more
comfortable
[Music]
okay so I have my shirt on the more I'm
in it the more I'm kind of like I think
I would wear this after this experiment
right before I left my house and I'd
first put the shirt on I was feeling
super empowered a minute I stepped
outside and I walked past people all of
a sudden all of that empowerment just
like fell out the window he just walked
past two people I was like I feel kind
of stupid in the shirt I went out this
weekend I went to West Hollywood
hopefully to pick up a man with my
fantastic advertisement just bracing
myself to go out and this beautiful
shirt I already spilled wine on my
[ __ ] shirt come on thoughts going
through my head wearing this where do
not look at me all right so the shirts
on yeah not wanting to look like a
complete [ __ ] douche bag I switch
shirts I literally talked to so many
people about the shirt they didn't even
see it and they just told me how
terrible of an idea was I'm gonna do it
it's too douchey
like how the hell do you wear something
like that I immediately kind of went on
the defensive like yeah [ __ ] dare
anyone to approach me like I dare
someone to ask about my single-dose okay
so I just got out of the grocery store
the bagger chick was like oh what's your
shirt then I was like it says single
like you can see what it says it's just
like oh that shirts awesome and I was
like Wayne it is and she was a guy wear
that I was in Trader Joe's and the
cashier was just like oh my gosh your
shirt is so funny like I would want that
and I was like really and she was like
now I would member I've gotten to this
point in my life where I don't really
think about what people think of me so
it was very weird to get sucked back
into a very young deixa where all I
could think about was what people were
thinking of me Mike what do you think of
my shirt
what's that supposed to mean what do you
think when you see someone to walk in
with this shirt would you like want to
ask me out you would yeah I really think
that this shirt is more of a deterrent
to people talking to me than anything
else I went to Universal Studios theme
park tons of people maybe one person
would be like yeah what's your name but
nothing I think I'm really tired of
wearing this shirt out in public anytime
someone walks by me on the sidewalk my
whole body clenches up and I hope that
they don't make eye contact with it no
one leave a single [ __ ] unintended about
this shirt I was more offended that
people think that I would wear this
shirt if anything I felt more single
wear this shirt I feel like people just
gave me weird looks and theory it makes
sense cuz you know your walking
billboard of your own product but it's
just now dating is cool
and I'd be so down to date people but
this is just kind of like rubbing it in
my face so I'm not dating someone right
now I will never wear the shirt again in
a weird way like I was kind of enjoying
the discomfort to me it just kind of
felt like people were looking at me and
maybe thinking that I was desperate and
I couldn't talk about it but I also
think that it was really great lesson
and that's not like talking and
explaining yourself sometimes it's gonna
stop people from perceiving you the way
you don't want to be perceived so
sometimes like you just have to embrace
it and do you and just say [ __ ] it think
what you want like while you're thinking
about me I'm thinking about you know
what's my next plan to become a boss
[ __ ] okay you know